[Music]
[Applause]
bills Rams tonight NBC and peacock
NFL kickoff at 8 30 Eastern on NBC in
peacock it'll be Mike Tirico Chris
Collinsworth Melissa Stark on the
sidelines and then it'll be the
Buccaneers at the Cowboys this weekend
that'll be Sunday Night Football and the
man calling all the action is Mike
turico NBC Sunday night football play by
play voice how is the voice Mike
um well what what time is it out here
Dan it's 7 24 so I think it's it's okay
it's warming up we'll be ready in about
you know 10 hours or whatever the heck
it is I was talking about most painful
loss that you've ever seen now I mean we
could flip that and say the most
incredible win you've ever seen right
but being on the sidelines when Seattle
through the interception against the
Patriots and Malcolm Butler to see a
shift like that happen in the span of a
couple of seconds yeah and then I was
there when Bill Buckner had the ball go
through his legs those are two of the
most now Boston did have one more game
that was game six Seattle had no more
chances but those are two of the more
painful losses that I've ever witnessed
I was there when Joe Carter homered off
Mitch Williams in Sky Dome that didn't
feel as dramatic as what happened with
Seattle
um do you have one that comes to mind
um I if you're leading me towards
buffaloes against Kansas City we can go
there in a second but March 30 1987
Keith freaking smart
Syracuse Indiana I mean that that's at
the at the Superdome in New Orleans I'm
student media at that time working at
War our College radio station where all
the Syracuse broadcasters work and uh
I'm sick we got to cover it and I'm not
calling the game I'm hosting the pregame
halftime post game and I'm in the third
row and I'm on that side of the bench
and we covered the you know what out of
Steve as Steve Alford Alford was not
going to get up a shot and he was
covered and Keith freaking smart made
the shot and um that that still hurts
March 30 1987 is still a dark day for me
I can't stand it I'm the only the only
thing made up for it was Syracuse won
the National Championship with Carmelo
Anthony in the dome in New Orleans so at
least going back in there hasn't been as
painful but to tonight that Bill's lost
against Kansas City when they walked off
the field with 13 seconds left they had
to feel like they were hosting the AFC
Championship game and that is just a
Crusher and that's what they've talked
about for seven months in Western New
York 13 seconds look 13 seconds joints
wide right
in Buffalo parlance you know and the
Music City miracle and all those plays
that they'll never forget happen to the
Buffalo team I mentioned this to start
the show if the Rams had not won the
Super Bowl last year
how many people would take the Rams
heading into this year it's almost like
they're avoiding them because they won
the Super Bowl and they might have
gotten better in the off season
yeah because you lose Von Miller and you
go man you lose Von Miller he made a
difference in pass rushing for the Rams
in the Super Bowl run those playoff
games but without Von Miller used that
money in a couple of places Bobby Wagner
so now you have a veteran great head of
the defense who has seen it all in his
10 years in Seattle and he stays in the
division comes to the Rams and then you
add Alan Robinson as a receiver and he
has not had a quarterback anywhere near
the level of Matthew Stafford so yes
Odell Beckham Jr is out he's not a part
of it because the ACL he still may come
back the ramps have left the locker for
him he's going to be on the field before
the game tonight so the Rams are putting
on the full schmooze to make sure hey
Odell come on back when you're healthy
and you're ready but in some ways they
might be a little bit better I think
it's going to take some time Whitworth
left tackle safety position remember
Weddle came in late and was key for them
in the playoffs but I I think you're
right there's that feeling of we haven't
seen anybody repeat in over a decade and
a half so why would you pick a team to
repeat when it just doesn't happen in
this NFL but this team has every
opportunity to I think when's the last
time you went down the roster and you
went oh that's going to be a tough name
to call
oh
um college games all the time college
games all the time
um you know so many different names so
many different countries being
represented in in football now uh
players who come for an opportunity yeah
so it was weekly with Notre Dame games
that's for sure
but how do you I it feels like the you
have analysts who just call him Tua now
like like like Giannis was The Greek
Freak you know that that we got to the
point where we're like I don't even want
to go there he just uh to a back to pass
oh the you know Giannis with the slam
well the key is they need a unique first
name that helps you out like even might
come up in the broadcast who knows the
pagulas own the bills there's daughter
Jessica had a great run at the US Open
lost in the quarterfinals to igash right
so which would be a great when I hear
igeon Tech the number one seed at the US
Open I think that is a Dan Patrick
highlight name still in my mind there
are names where DK would walk around
with the shot sheet the highlights go
round 10
and those are the best and then once
once the joke started you and Keith
you'd never let it go no so every time
would show up it was priceless TV so yes
I I still if there's a name you come
across you walk around and say to
yourself a hundred times before you get
on TV I remember when Nikolai
well when he first came up and I got the
shot sheet and I was doing the highlight
and I said how do you pronounce the
goalie cabibulan so the first time I
went on SportsCenter oh man am I playing
up Nikolai cabibulan he was Nick like a
bibulum with another save and then I get
done with the show and I get all these
voice messages hey it's hobby bull an
idiot I think ugh
this is the best you can screw up Ron
tug nut but I did
Nikolai cabibulan like damn it did you
did you do the highlight and I tugged
not made like seven Shades yes and I
said oh my God he saw more rubber than a
tire salesman Ron tugnut I think he had
like 73 saves or something right that's
right yeah Boston St Louis me I I can't
remember what I had for breakfast
yesterday but I remember like nights
like that doubling over usually I was
upstairs with Chris Myers getting ready
to do the 2 30 or the 2 A.M and you and
KO were doing the show and just there's
like laughter amongst the 10 people left
in The Newsroom thought those were funny
days and we played to the camera crew we
we we played to the floor direct that
was our audience so you never knew if it
was like have you made the camera crew
laugh then you're like all right maybe
somebody in America is appreciating this
exactly exactly I saw Van Pelt was on
last night they stayed uh they stayed
around to do at least the first segment
if not the whole show live after the
tennis ended and it was somewhere around
3 A.M Eastern Time midnight Pacific so
you know Scotty always goes on the show
and says it's whatever 12 16 a.m and I'm
not tired it's 3am and I'm tired
but we those those are the fun nights
too when we'd sit around waiting for the
West Coast baseball games to end
up top of the top of the ninth home team
trailing okay good our home team winning
that means good we may be on in two
pitches and invariably the Mariners
Bullpen and all due respect to the
Marines of the early 90s that Bullpen
sucked yeah I mean we had more nights
where we sat out there 10th inning 11th
inning 12th inning they gave up runs and
couldn't close the game there would be
times and it would if it would um seep
into how you called The Highlight like
you were so mad because this game went
12 Innings and Mike's schooler gave up a
home run and he goes my school her gives
up the Home Run and you know the Red Sox
win we're talking to Mike Trico be on
the call tonight with Chris Collinsworth
Melissa Stark and NFL kickoff at 8 30
Eastern last time you were truly nervous
at an event
first night of doing the Olympics in
2018 in South Korea that's the first
night Bob Costas was the Prime Time host
of the Olympics
um for whatever reason that moment was
like oh my oh my gosh really this is
like Jim McKay's job and Costas job and
now it's mine don't screw it up and
about a minute before I think everybody
else around was nervous for me because
you can tell when the Studio's a little
tense and uptight
our our studio in the broadcast Center
was a little tense and a little uptight
like about a minute before I just
started cracking a couple of jokes it
was like is everybody nervous in here
what's going on it's got really quiet in
here which was just kind of way to
disarm everybody including me just let
everyone know I was okay so that that
was the last time I was really
a little bit nervous now there's always
the adrenaline right of getting back on
the air and doing the show or doing a
game or doing something new but truly
nervous I think it was that
um are you Lions fan this year like how
do you feel about your Detroit Lions
this year well I I I'm agnostic of
course Dan is now a returning NFL voice
it's I love every team equally I and
Haiti of every every team equally
Collinsworth keeps telling me don't
worry they're going to hate you in like
two weeks I promise you it's just
different it comes with the territory it
comes to sit next to me
um you know I
I think the Hard Knocks thing was the
best thing the Lions could have done
because I I think folks had lost belief
in the team and the franchise and it
just gave it a face and a personality
and a juice and an enthusiasm and you
know you could have a lot of fun with
Dan Campbell and some of his sound bites
but if you watched Hard Knocks like I go
back to the second last episode they're
in Pittsburgh they played the Steelers
in the preseason he's addressing the
team in the locker room
and you could tell like Dan Campbell the
guy who knew from his decade of playing
that that locker room was going to be
missing about 25 guys because of cuts
but you could see that emotion so in
addition to the you know we're gonna
we're gonna eat people and I don't care
if you have one butt cheek and all the
stuff that he talked about all you know
silly stuff like there's a guy who
really cares about the players and
that's what I see here with Sean McVay
the guys who care about the players
that's what a player's coach is now do
you really give a darn about me and
what's going on in my life and can you
set that emotion and that atmosphere in
our locker room and uh I think the Lions
have that they were pretty close in a
bunch of games last year you know seven
seven or eight wins was not out of the
realm of possibility for them this year
I think I'll leave you with this a
couple of weeks ago you're interviewing
Rory just won the FedEx and you
emphasize the word this
to win the FedEx this year right was
that on purpose thousand percent you
know I I did end up saying given the
changing whatever landscape of golf at
that point right but you're not going to
sit there and start going to a live
conversation but
you know and and I've told you this off
there you're you're one of the best
people doing interviews because
if you use a few words in a question
then every word matters
and the emphasis on the words matter and
sometimes you know when you have a good
subject somebody who's going to be
willing to let you take them there
it's up to you to get them there and as
soon as I said this year with him he got
it he knew and he gave an exceptional
answer on not the Tour Championship or
the FedEx Cup but what it meant to do it
because he was the guy out front as the
face of all this
um so yeah it's you know and I I do say
that in all great respect and care and
love for you you know we all learn from
each other right I mean I pick up stuff
that iron does or Jim does or Joe does
or Al does or Kevin does with Fox that
you know hey that's a that's a good way
to do this we're all kind of taking a
bunch of ideas and putting them in our
own personality and one thing you were
always great about and still are
is asking a question the right way so
yeah good great great pick up by you I
guess the professor still got it uh I'm
observing always observing there but you
know I it was one of the first things I
brought up on the show that next day it
was just you know Rory you can if you
get to Rory and you get him in the right
situation he'll he'll take the Baton and
he'll keep running he doesn't hand it
off he'll keep running he'll do he'll do
another lap and that's what I loved it
was quick it was to the point the
emphasis was there he grabbed it seized
it
um and that's what made it you know a
great answer people always say boy you
ask great questions like how are the
answers because if the answers aren't
any good it doesn't matter how the
question is
and if you're sitting on our side of it
when somebody's giving a great answer
because you're thinking of the follow-up
you're listening for the follow-up right
and okay well they took that follow-up
well they keep going they took that
follow damn what are we going to do now
you took the next four questions because
your answer wasn't good it was
unbelievably good but that's uh that's
the the joy of the job the adrenaline of
the moment and being reactive to it I've
got like 8 000 things of prep here and
all this stuff that that stuff the fun
part is you get in the booth the game
kicks off and you don't know where
you're gonna go it's the three and a
half hour open book oral exam of did you
do your prep this week and I love the
energy of that and uh can't wait to do
it and then get on a plane and go to
Dallas and
pick up for the bucks and Cowboys on
Sunday for the opener Sunday night I
wasn't going to watch the game tonight
Paulie but now because Mike had a good
visit he selled it yeah now I'm gonna
what do you mean you weren't gonna watch
the game
get out of here see that's the actor in
me Mike you know I do I am an actor
just letting you play one on TV yes I'm
acting right now come on you're crazy uh
have fun tonight Mike we'll be there
critic I mean critiquing you
I look forward to your critiques thanks
pal thank you that's Mike Tirico he's
the voice of uh football night in
America Sunday Night Football with Chris
Collinsworth Melissa Starks on Melissa
Stark on the sideline